beware the demagogue who knows
everything because nearly every
demagogue ever has actually known
nothing Donald Trump is a demagogue you
tweet him that I just called him this
and tweet him again explaining to him
what a demagogue is this is a demagogue
late last Saturday a dumpster blew up on
23rd Street in New York the perfect 2016
campaign analogy of course also the
perfect opportunity for Donald J Trump
demagogue to per the definition be quote
a political leader who seeks support by
appealing to popular desires and
prejudices rather than by using rational
arguments so he got off his plane in
Colorado Springs and told the crowd
there that a bomb went off in New York
and nobody knows exactly what's going on
but boy are we living in a time we
better get very tough folks we better
get very very tough it's a terrible
thing that going on in our world in our
country and we're going to get tough and
smart and vigilant Trump said this
before any official had confirmed it was
a bomb before any expert could literally
have any idea what was going on he
couldn't wait he couldn't wait literally
because he's a compulsive talker a
gossiping child he couldn't wait
metaphorically because he clearly knows
terrorist attacks benefit him he needs
them alone in this country to him they
are preferable to you know no more
terrorism they fit his product perfectly
in this vast free-floating sense of
panic and the need for vigilance or is
the right word vigilantism that he is so
successfully selling it had to be a bomb
it had to be evidence of the bast plot
against his voters that to use his words
only he can fix nobody knows what's
going on Donald Trump said true at least
of all Donald Trump we're gonna have to
do something extremely tough he said
Monday morning like what he was asked by
Steve Doocy the other guy accused by
gretchen carlson over there
like knocked the hell out of them and we
have to get everybody together and we
have to lead for a change because we're
not knocking
Trump has no idea what to do except
knock them there is no plan secret or
otherwise there is nothing he is
concealing there is no deal for him to
make Trump confused actually Trump is
just Shakespeare's King Lear I will have
such revenge's on you both that all the
world shall I will do such things what
they are yet I know not but they shall
be the terrors of the earth no plan no
clue just a lot of knocking them Donald
Trump has had no plan against terrorism
Isis or otherwise for a long time he has
been doing this terrors of the earth
King Lear bit for at least 16 months
when in reality to paraphrase Winston
Churchill he would not know the
difference between a first lieutenant
and a mark 48 torpedo may 27 2015 - Fox
News I do know what to do and I would
know how to bring Isis to the table or
beyond that defeat Isis very quickly and
I'm not going to tell you what it is
tonight
even the Fox host was appalled why won't
you tell we need all the help we can get
I don't want the enemy to know what I'm
doing unfortunately I'll probably have
to tell at some point but there is a
method of defeating them quickly and
effectively and having total victory
hate him or love him there is a small
germ of logic in that quote where there
would have been had Trump not been lying
then he wasn't keeping the plan from
Isis he was keeping it from Ted Cruz and
Marco Rubio the next month to the Des
Moines Register newspaper the problem
with politics is if I tell you right now
everyone else is going to say wow what a
great idea you're gonna have 10
candidates go and use it and they're
gonna forget where it came from which is
me but no I have an absolute way of
defeating Isis because trumps plan to
defeat Isis was an absolute way but he
would keep it a secret for a year and a
half rather than tell America's generals
right then in June 2015 so instead we
have the June beheading
in France the November Paris attacks at
the Bataclan and the stadium and the
restaurants the German attacks the San
Bernadino attacked last December all
those would not have happened if Donald
J Trump super genius had said this will
work general even if he demanded public
credit for it afterwards which he would
have gratefully gotten April 2016
Trump's clownish foreign policy speech
for Isis quote I have a simple message
for them their days are numbered I won't
tell them where and I won't tell them
how but they're going to be gone Isis
will be gone if I'm elected president
and they'll be gone quickly so if he'd
gone to the generals then with his plan
no Isis and no attack on the pulse Club
in Orlando in June and no suicide attack
at anspach in Germany in July and no
priest killed in Rouen and France no
Isis lunatic driving a truck down the
boardwalk at nice during holiday
fireworks killing 86 and injuring
hundreds no whatever this was in New
York and New Jersey last weekend all
because Donald Trump wanted to keep his
foolproof plan a secret from the
generals from the public from the
families of those who would yet suffer
and die and finally this month we get an
inkling of the great plan Trump at
Greenville North Carolina we're going to
convene my top generals and give them a
simple instruction they will have 30
days to submit to the Oval Office a plan
for soundly and quickly defeating Isis
we have no choice
Trump could have also added and we have
no plan the secret plan the foolproof
plan the absolute way of defeating Isis
plan the one he wouldn't tell and those
hundreds of people who could have been
saved by it I guess were instead
murdered the one he alone could devise
because as he has said he knows more
about Isis than the generals the big
plan is to tell the generals they have
30 days to think up a big plan Trump had
no plan he has no plan he will have no
plan he is not a leader he's not tough
he's not concerned about Isis except as
a sales to
to get your vote he knows nothing he has
nothing except he has a tweet once again
someone we were told is okay turns out
to be a terrorist who wants to destroy
our country and its people how did he
get through system well my understanding
about that is his grandfather emigrated
here from Bremen in 1885 and then he
changed the family name from groom to
what it is now and the guy you're
referring to is that man's grandson
Donald Trump is our national fame that's
the closure I'm Keith Olbermann watch
this space